So here we have the figure that we know and love
of the input domain for some software under test.
If we think about what the generative random tester is going to do,
what it's probably really going to do is cluster them in some part
because it's very hard to cover the actual full space of inputs.
But in any case, they're going to be spread out over some part of the region.
What a mutation-based random tester is going to do is start with some known input,
and what it's going to do is randomly modify it,
and so it's going to end up with test cases
that in some sense are kind of in the same neighborhood as the original input.
And so our mutation-based random tester is going to be able to access points like this.
If we start with a different input, it's going to be able to get points like this.
And so what's happening is we're exploring interesting parts of the input domain,
and it could be that we could have never reached this part of the input domain
using any kind of a generative random test case generator that we have time to make.
So this approach is extremely useful and extremely valid.
But on the other hand, it's generally limited to
exploring sort of a region of the input space that's close to the starting point.
One thing that you should be asking yourself right now is,
what are the operators that we use to mutate test cases to create new random test cases?
And so let's look at that a little bit.